si on me revient une fois de plus sur le
devant de la scène avec un tout nouveau
smartphone non griffé xiaomi mais
griffer poko alors je sais pas si vous
savez tout a commencé avec le pot
cofondé fin il ya quelques années à
l'étranger poko phone est une entité qui
se sépare de choi qui reste la même
maison voilà c'est toujours la même
chose mais malgré tout c'est une marque
à part entière et c'est la raison pour
laquelle voyez vous voyez marqué nulle
part xiaomi là dessus mais bien un poco
qui est une marque et qui s'affirme
comme étant une marque donc on retrouve
aujourd'hui un nouveau smartphone de
poko jouit toujours joli quand même
c'est le x3 nfc noms bizarres x3 je suis
d'accord à nf c est ce que c'est ce qui
est le plus sexy dire nfc dans une malle
bon je ne sais pas quand il a voulu se
positionner dessus mais en tout cas ça
fonctionne donc c'est un nouveau
smartphone que j'ai gardées quel hacker
tout mignon qui tout sympa j'aime déjà
cette partie là la regardaient las ce
module photo c'est assez original et
puis surtout la revoyez jeux d'écriture
poko qui ressort je me sens assez cool
donc on va se regarder ce nouveau
smartphone de chez audi poko x3 nfc on
va regarder s'il intéressant s'il est
fait pour vous quels sont les promesses
qui fait qu'on est sur un smartphone
surtout qui vient se positionner dans le
l'entrée du milieu de gamme un peu tard
donc j'ai tout vous détailler on y va et
si vous aviez l'habitude de regarder les
vidéos vous le savez vous connaissez
l'histoire je vous demande d'aider
videmment de venir me rejoindre dans la
communauté vous abonner comme ça vous
saurez tout sur l'actu tech les
nouveautés smartphones les mots qui sont
dignes à tort les tablettes compagnie
tout ça tout ça est bien évidemment
parle aussi des usages on parle de vous
on parle de plein de choses
intéressantes sur les produits tech dont
je vous invite à venir cliquer sur le
petit bouton rouge si ce n'est pas déjà
fait en dessous vous accédez la cloche
comme ça vous serez notifié dès qu'une
nouvelle vidéo arrivera et ça c'est
vraiment cool on va commencer tout de
suite par la boîte voir un petit peu ce
qu'on nous propose bon ça reste très
très simple avec un accès rapide aux
applications google que vous utilisez le
plus beau en valeur leurs mollets les
couleurs les codes couleur de peau qu à
l'intérieur on continue à trouver ici le
branding poko qui est vraiment vraiment
vraiment assumer ensuite ici et vous
avez une petite coque de protection et
ça c'est cool en plastique de courir son
tiroir de cartes sim bien évidemment
pour le smartphone normalement est ici
et lorsqu'on ouvre tout ça on se
retrouve avec son bloc de charge qui est
assez massive jeu tout vous dire dessus
dans quelques instants le smartphone
quant à lui est très sympa et je vous le
dis ce que j'aime bien c'est ce côté là
marqué poko qui vient ressortir je
trouve ça vraiment très élégant plutôt
bien vu on aller coûte un peu strié la
force trade est toujours très compliqué
avec la lumière de
vous montrez ça comme ça un délit petite
streak qui sont là on va retrouver
effectivement toute cette partie c'est
un peu être à poussière mais bon une
fois qu'on est passé là dessus et bien
c'est très sympa avec quatre caméras on
va regarder ça dans quelques instants
sur le côté le capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui font office de bouton et
qu'il est verrouillé extrêmement
rapidement donc ça s'est très très bien
les boutons de volume sur le dessous on
va avoir un haut parleur qui se
positionne la une prise jack oui vous ne
rêvez pas une prise jack c'est très très
bien de la recharge en usb ses 1600 côté
on a un tiroir de karting qui peut
accueillir 12 le signe ça c'est cool
et puis si on a de l'infrarouge vous
n'avez pas certification eal p 68
certification vous assure que votre
smartphone est certifié résistant à
l'eau et à la poussière et si c'est pas
le cas par contre chez eux mais nous dit
enfin beaucoup nous dit qu'on a un
revêtement p2i nano résistance
d'éclaboussures bon je pense que si vous
rencontrez un petit peu d'eau quelques
éclaboussures
ça devrait quand même bien se passer
vous avez un dos plastique un smartphone
qui fait ces quelques 215 grammes et à
l'avant on retrouve un verre corning
gorilla glass un qui vient de protéger
leurs ici on a un écran lcd de 6,67
pouces résolution full hd plus de 1400
par 1080 à 395 pixels par pouce et un
ratio vingt neuvième
on est vraiment dans l'air du temps est
ce qui est surtout intéressant ici et on
le voit bien quand on va dans les
paramètres quand on va dans affichage on
a un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
salon vous choisissez si vous voulez
rester 60 hertz vous pouvez vous
viendrez un peu économiser la batterie
mais vous allez surtout un switch
intelligence appelle ça le dynamique
soulist vous permet de switcher entre 50
60 90 ou 100 variable en fonction des
besoins de l'application qui va tourner
derrière mais ça c'est vraiment ce qui
est dans l'air du temps et sans gros
argument marketing et notamment pour le
gaming et puis pour des réseaux sociaux
comme instagram
on va récupérer beaucoup de fidélité est
ce que vous allez venir scrollé pas noté
qui si vous avez une fréquence
d'échantillonnage tactile de 240 m un
écran qui certifiait lutter contre la
lumière bleue et qui certifiait hdr 10
pour venir visionner tout votre contenu
en ligne autres banques et tout le monde
a ici des haut parleurs stéréo
la qualité audio est pas trop trop mal
on n'a pas beaucoup beaucoup puissance
on en a un coût mais c'est pas
complètement dingue mais bien le saut
qui sort de votre haut-parleurs qui est
planqué là mais également du haut
parleur qui vous servira bombe à ces
défis
l'idée c'est ça vous apporter plus de
spatialisation puisque vous avez le son
qui vient d'un côté et de l'autre c'est
un côté plus immersif notamment pour me
regarder des films des séries mais
également pour venir jouer à des jeux
sont normales dans quelques instants
donc ça c'est très bien en plus de ça
vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 pour venir
connecter votre casque sans fil ou vos
petits bugs tout ce que vous voulez très
pratique mais surtout ce qui est
intéressant et on retrouve beaucoup dans
les smartphones d'entrée milieu de gamme
ce sont des petites prises diack qui
elle par contre sont vraiment préserver
donc prévenir brancher votre casque la
qualité au casque est pas mal sans être
trop dingue on a un son qui reste quand
même beaucoup basé dans le médium n'a
pas un spa qui est extrêmement large et
on n'a pas non plus un très gros volume
sonore
ça va venir évitez d'un autre côté de
vous abîmer les oreilles mais soyez
quand même rassuré est tranquille pour
l'expérience multimédia safra la faire
côté performances on tourne sur un
snapdragon à 732 g octas core cadencé
jusqu'à 2 3 giga hertz honda une adreno
618 et on a surtout si j'ai gadrat mon
épée ddr 4x et soit 64 giga de stockage
soit 128 ennuis fs 2.0 ce qui nous
confère résultats sur en tout 2 283 1695
est-ce qu'il va le positionner en 48ème
position en dessous notamment du raid
minaude suite pro mais également au
dessus du raid me not neuf pros on a
notamment ici à technologie liquid
cooled 1.0 pour le refroidissement sur
un smartphone qui chauffent pas
particulièrement qui est plutôt agréable
et qui pour gainey se tiendra très très
bien et le fait d'avoir une fois de plus
des haut parleurs stéréo là dessus c'est
vraiment extrêmement coule donc pour
l'expérience de gamer expérience
multimédia on a un smartphone qui est
vraiment très très bien et complètement
adapté dans ce segment trie les marques
mettent des grosses batteries c'est
souvent un argument marketing en lisant
vous avez un smartphone d'entrée milieu
de gamme et vous avez une très grosse
autonomie un smartphone qui ne vous
lâchera pas et qui vous emmènera partout
alors ici poco xiaomi ont fait
exactement la même chose avec une très
grosse batterie de 5160 milliampères
heures et une charge rapide de 33 watts
inclus dans la boîte ce qui vous permet
de recharger votre smartphone de 0 à 60
2 % en 30 minutes et de 0 à 100% en un
peu plus d'une
en 65 minutes pour être extrêmement
précis autant dire qu'ici vous allez
pouvoir regarder votre smartphone sur un
usage modéré deux jours une journée et
demie son problème et savait évidemment
fluctuer en fonction de votre vos usages
côté logiciel on tourne sur me wade 2012
j'en ai déjà parlé jeudi à tout présenté
dans la vidéo justement de présentation
2012 il invite à y faire un petit tour
si vous la connaissez pas comme ça vous
saurez tout vous avez le tiroir
d'application vous avez des paramètres
qui ont été un petit peu revu et corrigé
que c'est très lisible avec de jolies
icônes en tout cas ça marche très très
bien une fois de plus vous rendre à ma
vidéo basé sur un android 10 votre gros
arguments mis en avant par xiaomi sur ce
smartphone shiomi peau qu une fois de
plus et bien sûr les capteurs photo vous
avez ici pas moins de quatre capteurs
photo à l'arrière une caméra principale
de 64 mégapixels avec le capteur de sony
c'est la sony et 1682 ici on ouvre à f
1.89 et vous avez notamment et
écologique est excellente vous avez
également un ultra grand-angle de 13
mégapixels avec un champ de vision 219
degrés ouvrant à f 2.2 et vous avez deux
petite caméra de 2 mégapixels de la
macro qui ouvre à f 2.4 et un capteur de
profondeur qui ouvre également à f 2.4
tandis qu'à l'avant vous avez une caméra
de celle fille de 20 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.2 faisant les photos qui
sont réalisés avec le pot coïc siii nfc
capteur principal écouter ce que dans
l'ensemble le résultat est assez
correcte c'est vraiment un peu saturé
mais une fois de plus on a n'a pas de
chien ont mis là dessus et on le
retrouve
mais malgré tout le résultat est
vraiment honnête et fonctionnent très
bien on pas sur le très grand temps mais
on l'a tous qu'on a une différence de
colorimétrie le ciel n'est pas du même
le lac août un peu plus pastel bon une
fois de plus dans cette gamme de
produits c'est pas anormal ultra grand
angle ultra grand-angle pour des photos
en plein jour ça fera le taf et pour
capter des monuments avec un grand champ
de vision est bien serra très très bien
ultra grand temps une fois de plus c'est
bien saturée quand même on se rapproche
ici avec un zoom x de leur foi 2 vous
pouvez y aller mais n'allez pas jusqu'au
x 10 comme vous le voyez là c'est
vraiment pas terrible
x 2 ça fera le boulot parce qu'on vient
vraiment croupit dans l'image sur le
capteur principal donc ça va fort existe
c'est pas très beau fois de savard x 10
on oublie alors la macro je suis
toujours - fan - c'est un côté qui vient
vraiment un peu lisse et il ya quotas
peu too much as beaucoup de bruit ici
bon c'est pas fou si vous voulez faire
un peu de maquereaux
prouver mais vous attendez pas à ce que
ça fasse des miracles la caméra tel film
est plutôt pas mal a toujours tendance
un petit peu alice aimé ça il faut de
plus c'est la patte de xiaomi mais ça
fonctionnera pas trop mal pour quelques
souvenirs
le mode portrait est aussi pas mauvais
mais limitée par la puissance du
processeur il a un petit peu de mal par
endroits mais gimont va pas non plus
faire beaucoup de photos avec ce mode là
voyez au niveau des doigts des cons
propre et syfy la scène c'est un peu
plus dur mais dans l'ensemble c'est
quand même relativement correct lepoko
ex 3 à 9 c est donc bien un smartphone
qui vient se positionner dans l'entrée
du milieu de gamme ou dans le haut de
gamme de l'entrée de gamme enfin on est
vraiment dans ce segment là un
smartphone que je trouve en tout cas
assez cool et je donne des informations
sur le das parce qu'il faut quand même
qu'on se dise tout est bien le d'asson
et hadass tête de 0,55 convoité par
kilogramme da score de 0.98 watts par
kilogramme et un tassement de 1,99 watts
par kilogramme est un smartphone qui
sera disponible à la vente à partir du
10 septembre prochain dans deux
configurations 6 + 64 giga halle de
stockage otaries de 229 euros 99 et 6
plus 128 go de stockage au tarif de 269
euros 90 voilà tout ce que j'avais à
vous dire aujourd'hui sur ce nouveau
smartphone de xiaomi poco poco xiaomi
sais pas comment vous trouvez vous le
trouver intéressant ce x3 nfc
qu'est ce que vous pensez du nom ex 3
nfc poko qu'est ce que vous pensez cette
couleur alors moi je voulais ici dans la
couleur bleue alors le nom exact c'est
le néon bleu alors moi le double je les
aime beaucoup j'aime bien ce côté
reflets qui est vraiment très sympa et
très actuelle il existe également en
électrique purple en saveurs gré et
enfants tom wright j'ai vraiment envie
de rencontrer un jour la personne qui
choisit les noms des couleurs pour les
smartphones en outre l'équipe marketing
mais bon voilà c'est très sympa moi
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup cette couleur c'est très cool
d'avoir l'écriture poko qui sort en plus
il ya un vrai côté là branding pour la
marque pour le faire boire davantage à
l'heure après ce smartphone qu'il faut
quand même venir protéger ses biens que
vous ayez cette coque transparente à
l'intérieur et puis si vous voulez
vraiment profiter de ce nom comme ça
pourquoi pas a vous de me dire donc ce
que vous en pensez en bas on commente a
personnellement j'aime bien
j'aime bien ce que propose pour coller
dessus on n'est pas sur un smartphone
qui est extrêmement puissante qui frappe
vraiment bien le taf dans sa catégorie
grosse autonomie appareil photo qui est
très cool sur le capteur principal de 64
mégapixels et c'est vraiment là dessus
qu'il faut venir chercher la photo le
reste un petit peu gadget en du cran qui
est assez de qualité des haut parleurs
stéréo tout ça autour des 2
150 euros bon ça se tient très bien très
beau produit en tout cas j'aime beaucoup
je te demande et vous très bientôt pour
continuer à parler tech parce qu'on a
plein de choses à se dire plein d'actu
plein plein plein plein de belles choses
on nous envoie beaucoup d'amour ce
rendez vous extrêmement rapide on a très
vite arrêté le caca
[Musique]